[Music]
the Clark County School District has
closed its investigation into an officer
captured on video taking a student to
the ground so as you can imagine this is
sparking a lot of backlash among several
civil rights groups including one
representing the student in court eight
news now education reporter Joshua
peguero joining us with the latest on
this situation Joshua hello Denise and
Kirsten this incident happened back on
February 9th as you can see at Durango
high school you can see the officer grab
the student from the back and take them
to the ground it's an action CCSD says
does not violate any District policy
it's one thing to see how you feel about
something that's a complete another
thing to um to allege misconduct without
knowing what actually took place Matthew
Caldwell was the president of ccsd's
police union he says the officer who was
investigated will not be fired and
described him as one of the most honest
people he knows nobody likes to be cast
you know in a certain way if somebody's
saying things about you that that damage
your your reputation nobody wants to
hear that in a statement the ACLU of
Nevada says quote hearing that CCSD has
closed its investigation into its
officers misconduct without requesting
an interview with our clients raises
serious questions about the district's
actual willingness to hold its officers
accountable end quote the ACLU is
representing the student in this video
the incident let's say protest outside
ccsd's administration building and both
superintendent Dr Jesus Jara and cscsd
police chief Mike blackeye having to
testify before lawmakers I don't see
where we've taken into account that you
all are dealing with children at a
school environment
is the president of the NAACP of Las
Vegas and he blasts this decision as
anti-democratic the footage itself was
plain and anybody with good working eyes
could see that that young man was
treated poorly and that that officer
acted in a way that was not becoming of
a professional a specially given that
there was no proof or no evidence that
his own life was endangered savoir says
the NAACP will still seek to hold Jara
accountable to understand that there
will be no repercussions no consequence
that doesn't make me feel good and I
imagine that it doesn't make our parents
and the valley feel very good either
now in a statement CCSD says the police
department's used to force policy
follows a standard established by the
U.S Supreme Court Denise